um I hope the film will save the world
etc sites hush um um I guess I got
involved with the film about five years
ago and meeting a good funny story as
working Oh with sea Shepherd in
Australia and I got taken over to this
artist guiding Howie's house we saw in
the movie I know I did them how he was
but they just dropped me off there and a
bottle of wine later me and how you were
driving over to dave's house around the
corner and I showed up at days house and
he had no idea who I was and I didn't
really know he was and he didn't really
say a word to me the whole night they're
going to attention to me um but at the
very end I stood on a video and he was
kind of laying down sort of going to
sleep and his own party and soon as the
video turned on there was a sound of a
whale and date with it up his head and
watch the video sideways the whole way
for five minutes and then when it is
over he pajamas hood and then I left a
Michael okay that's a weird weird
experience in Australia with these
trippy surfer guys um and then a few
days later he emailed me and said hey
you know want to collaborate on this
thing I'm putting all this movie life
like liquid and can I put the video on
there and I said that'd be sweet and so
I think that's kind of not knowing and
then just met these amazing people and
for the Humane Society of the United
States and especially at the Hollywood
offices as you can see is the type of
movie I love to get behind because not
only can you enjoy the experience and
sort of you know have a nice movie to
watch but it has a higher purpose for
Mina now higher meaning and that's the
kind of films we're looking to get
behind and try to help out filmmakers in
various ways you know whether that's
just research or whether it's actually
getting really involved with this so any
of you pledging filmmakers out there
make sure you contact the Hollywood
office
we can help stereos right way hopefully
and I'd like to just get a shout out
real quick to some of the people are
really or here there's so many of you to
help I made made this possible